hey youtubers is Charlie so this week on
Game of Thrones we got some big
callbacks to Braavos including Syrio
Forel fate and we got to see Sansa in
the Vale which was a huge deal but I
really feel like all the energy was at
Craster's real quick shout out if you're
finding me for the first time I just do
weekly Game of Thrones videos for each
episode in a whole bunch of bonus videos
be sure to subscribe to get everything I
even do a weekly giveaway that starts in
this video right now all you have to do
to participate is be a subscriber and
leave a comment so because I'm also
getting ready to hit 200,000 subscribers
I'm doubling it too but I'll talk about
that after my review careful for
spoilers from the episode if you haven't
seen it yet but here my top five moments
number five Lysa and Littlefinger in
case you don't remember from Season one
she is Looney Tunes crazy
mostly crazy for Littlefinger it's kind
of tragic how much she's taken advantage
of her lifelong obsession with him but
here are the CliffsNotes on their
historic love triangle with Catelyn
Stark Littlefinger always loved Catelyn
as a boy but Kalin like most teenagers
was not always into him but on the side
Lysa started to become obsessed with
Littlefinger because Littlefinger
couldn't have Catelyn
he took Lysa as a consolation prize and
you know basically took her virginity
only making her obsession worse but she
was forced to marry a much much much
older Jon Arryn who ruled the Eyrie Jon
Arryn ended up discovering Joffrey was a
bastard preseason one that Littlefinger
who was working a long con at the time
used the licensed obsession to get hurt
- poisoned Jon Arryn her husband and
send that letter to Catelyn to make her
think that the Lannisters were
responsible which was part of the reason
why Catelyn took Tyrion to the Vale to
be executed in season one so as you can
see everything is connected it gets
really really complicated but when she
says little things like you know
dropping poison into Jon Aaron's goblet
it's a huge deal that was really only
half of the things that happened in the
Vale this episode we can unpack the
freaking hilarious sex framing down in
the comments but the big takeaway from
Sansa this week is that Lysa it looks
like she could flip out at any moment
and just try to do something awful so
keep your eyes peeled on Lysa she is a
loaded gun but her son Robin is just as
crazy as Joffrey just in the opposite
direction you know he's just crazy at
the opposite end of the spectrum who
else felt really really bad for Sansa
whenever he just farted the red wedding
out of his
number four you cannot run from the iron
bank this may not have seemed like a big
deal at the time but I think this iron
bank plot will become much much bigger
in the next couple of episodes how
surprise for you when Tywin said that
all their gold mines had been exhausted
they're still rich but there's no new
money coming in all those Wars he funded
and the money he lent to Robert took a
huge chunk of their wealth so that's why
they need the Tyrells they're basically
the only other super wealthy family in
Westeros right now Mark Gatiss is
actually playing someone who works for
their'n bank of Braavos but we don't
know which episode he's gonna debut in
or how big his parts gonna be but it was
just one of the first big call-outs to
Braavos in the episode which I thought
was really awesome number three
Daenerys does what Queens do I like the
casual way that Daario talked about
taking the Marines fleet of ships he
made it sound like they just pinched him
it's basically enough to carry the force
they have right now to Westeros so
technically if they wanted to they could
probably take the Iron Throne and enough
people would flock to her banner to help
them subdue the rest of Westeros they
really wanted it to feel like Daenerys
could go either way but in doing so you
know all of her good work freeing the
slaves would be undone so she's sticking
around in Mereen for the long haul to
just and try and take care of slavers
Bay but old enemies and a couple new
ones are cropping up they named dropped
Cleon a former slave who's taken over a
stupor he's gonna be important in the
future probably I don't know if they
cast the role but remember his name back
in young hide the wise masters have
taken back power so they're also going
to be a group Daenerys will have to face
again we did not see the Dragons this
week but because there are a couple of
scenes in the trailers of Daenerys in
her throne room we haven't seen yet I
expect there to be some dragon related
scenes in the next couple of episodes
number two Brienne and Podrick are the
anti hound and Arya yes it is a bummer
that Jaime is not with Brienne but I
love the comedy that they brought to the
episode when the whole world is burning
or freezing around you it's just nice to
get a little bit of relief so she's
slowly warming up to him but it was
really when she learned about pod saving
Tyrion during the Battle of Blackwater
that really sealed the deal I also feel
like this foreshadow pod maybe he's
saving Brienne at some point this season
so hopefully we'll get that payoff he's
not super at cooking rabbits but he is
there when you really need him I also
love the way they visually
connected pod talking about running his
spear through the back of that guy's
skull with Jon Snow
killing Carl and my number one WTF
moment no surprise here Jon Snow versus
Carl we are gonna miss you burn gorman
you were an amazing villain on Game of
Thrones in case you were wondering he
died inside Craster's keep and because
they lit it on fire I think he burnt too
so he will not come back as a wight they
really took the sword plate to the next
level in this episode you know we also
got Oreos water dancing in another scene
but Jon versus Carl was just a great
fight scene we don't get a lot of scenes
that are that crazy I feel like David
and Dan did a really good job developing
Carl as a villain so that this final
fight really did feel like a high point
of the episode that shot at Jon sword
though that will go down is one of the
all-time best killing blows on the show
not quite as big as Ned Stark's
beheading grant you but definitely top 5
but now it's your turn let me know what
was your favorite moment you know was it
Jon versus Carl was it Sansa in the
Eyrie or was it Arya and the Hound but
there are a couple really big moments
that we need to pay attention to but
they didn't necessarily make my top 5 so
here they are in no particular order
first off Arya is water dancing again
and she let the Hound note that he is on
her list of people to kill I was so
happy that needle could not penetrate
his armor I just love all their scenes
together so I do not want him to go away
anytime soon
they're like the anti pod and Brienne or
pod and Brienne are like the anti Aryan
hound
let's actually just call them team [ __ ]
the king in case you missed it to that
other big call-out to Braavos was in the
form of the Hound talking about serios
fate it was a big call out to the fandom
because everyone always wonders you know
did he die did he not die The Hound
thought the idea that Meryn Trant could
kill him was ridiculous he basically
made it seem like Meryn Trant could not
kill himself with his own blade if he
tried so if you believe him that means
that Serio is still alive somewhere out
there in reality George R Martin never
revealed serios fate and he still hasn't
in every interview I've ever seen
anytime anyone ever asked them he
refuses to say whether Sirius alive or
dead or confirm it but let me know what
you think in the comments below you know
is Syria alive or is he dead then we
have to follow up with bran
it looks like he's back on track to find
that giant weirwood from their visions
poor Hodor - did you see the look on his
face when he realized he killed luck but
the real major name-drop
the episode I felt like was the sand
snakes Oberon talked about his eight
daughters I know a lot of you have been
asking me whether or not we'll see any
of them this season but based on the
pacing of the episodes and the story and
given the fact that we're halfway done
with the season I don't think the show's
gonna bring them on until season five at
the earliest if there's any other really
important things that you saw in the
episode that I didn't include in my
video be sure to write it below in the
comments but overall I gave the episode
of solid a - they did an amazing job of
paying off this carl plot even though
carl really wasn't in that many scenes
this season
I think burn gorman just really nailed
evil I hope he plays some more villains
in the future he looked like he had so
much fun playing the part then from a
visual standpoint the way they revealed
the veil on the Eyrie was just
breathtaking you go from the bloody
gates this horrible claustrophobic kill
box to that panoramic CG shot of the
castle at the top of the mountain
it was just like Daenerys scanning the
landscape of murine earlier this season
the idea is is that Sansa is supposed to
be safe from all the armies there but
because of crazypants Lysa and Robin
she's probably in just as much danger as
she was back at King's Landing from an
emotional standpoint the only thing that
really didn't land with me in the
episode was where bran had to decide to
turn away from John I think it's just
because I've read the books and in the
books that scene never happened so it
was a little surreal for me this whole
Crestor subplot John's reunion with
summer though was just so awesome that
really did touch me but probably just
because I'm a big dog person
I've had Labrador Retrievers my whole
life so I know what it's like to love a
big animal like summer really I didn't
expect the episode to try and top that
big white Walker scene from last week
but the Craster subplot felt like it
almost got there I kind of feel like
that whole mirror subplot was
telegraphing Karl dying horrible death
you know it's like you're a horrible
person so you're gonna die horrible
death even though that doesn't always
happen on the show the fact that John
ended up doing it Podrick style was just
icing on the cake get him in the back of
the skull so let me know if you have any
other lasting questions about the
episode like usual my Q&A will post
tomorrow be sure to subscribe to get it
and again because I'm getting ready to
hit 200,000 subscribers and I just want
to say thank you to you guys for being
so amazing you're so awesome I'm
doubling the giveaway I'm giving away
two gift cards so based on the teaser it
looks like we're gonna see Terrance
trial so I think next week is gonna be
really exciting I can't wait
see the trial play out so right now
click here to get that Q&A video the
annotation as soon as I post it and
click here to learn more about the last
great war with the White Walkers and the
building of the wall thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives everybody go hug a dog if
they have a dog right now just go give
him a hug